got a lot of units at the moment £60,000
turnover that's a huge business really
that you've got now when I started I
written my goals down I WR go 10 essays
by the end of the year oh God that in 6
months how much are you making roughly
monthly turnovers around about 60,000
half of that profit damn bro got to keep
persistence persistence is key £3,000 a
month it's no joke is it when you have
to convince an agent to work with you
it's quite difficult getting your foot
in the door but once you've got one
agent that sees it then they'll start
picking up the phone and saying oh we
got landord we got another landord and
they'll stop bringing you loads of deals
one of my Studios is bringing back two
grand profits and I've never thought
that was possible now I'm doing
it Asim welcome to winners on the
Wednesday brother you've grown and
scaled your portfolio super quick you
know you went from like what one
Inherited property couple of things that
you done in Pakistan to now you're
controlling 6 million pound worth of
property yeah last year's been crazy
it's changed my life you know um I've
had a lot on it's been a joury Journey
but it's been fun at the same time I've
learned a lot when you came to the crash
course the one pound crash course I
think if I remember rightly you were
like a bit skeptical and a bit unsure I
come
twice yeah skeptical was understatement
you know um
firstly I doubted you I doubted the
whole process I thought you know it's
too good to be true this that the other
I come first time um and I just didn't
have enough time to go into it and start
putting things into practice so I'll
come again second time I thought you
know let's just do this yeah yeah get on
to it you know actions so yeah it's the
uh it was it's been crazy and you've
done in five months you've taken on how
many properties in five months well 11
we' got a few more so we're in the sixth
month now so I've got about 13 to in
process at the moment do you ever now do
you ever just like pinch yourself and
think like what the heck crazy I look at
the numbers now thinking wow wow I
haven't even had time to you know proper
concentrate on the numbers and uh do the
backend stuff but and it's funny because
now as well obviously we you know we get
to know each other a bit and you've been
doing some mentoring and things like
that but if there's someone that's new
that's just starting out like now you're
that person that's saying to them oh do
this and systemize it this way and and
and now you know and it's crazy to think
that when you first came to the crash
course you were the person at the back
of the room thinking nah man I'm not
sure about this and now you're actually
helping others and pulling people up so
just in the last week I've helped to I
Source One property at uh from one of my
landlords out of my patch so I sour
there helping them bring it up they've
just had a six round booking just
yesterday helped another Academy member
Matt who's uh he was finding it hard to
close the deal he was finding the deal
so I just went and there b just closed
it and he shouted you out for that
because he'd been banging his head off
brick wall for a few months he kept
saying to me like man what am I doing
wrong what am I doing wrong so no I
appreciate that so yeah just been to
closed it for him and you know when he
gets that um up and running I'll be
helping him for the process as well
that's so cool yeah it's about a given
bag where is your patch East London and
Essex okay and that's where you live
that's where I live as well yeah so talk
to me about I mean right now how much
are you making roughly in in in in
revenue or in profit every month uh
monthly turnover is around about 60,000
60 Grand yeah 60,000 yeah 60,000 a month
Yeah Yeah from the 12 properties and
damn bro um that half of that's profit
so clean profit so you're making about
30 grand a month yeah yeah just under
mate respect for that that's insane
that's like an annual salary yeah in a
month that's right yeah what's should
talk to me through your business model
what's your model so we do uh rent to
service accommodation where why we get
properties of the landlords on rent so
I'm not owning nothing I'm getting the
offering and we charge super rent
nightly rates so for example one of my
Studios which was my first one uh I pay
the landlord like £1,000 uh a month bang
one And1 a night you know it's bringing
back two and a half 3,000 two grand
profit take out the build
so geez just just on one studio and it's
quite a simple business model really
isn't it I mean of course there's
there's a lot to running a business
there's all the the nitty-gritty but the
basic premise is then you're renting
properties from landlords giving them
the rent that they want yeah long-term
leases but then you're getting
permission from the landlord and making
sure the property is suitable to to rent
it out on a nightly basis yeah yeah it's
crazy it's a crazy system I've never
thought that was possible when I was
looking now now I'm doing it what did
you think when I first talked about that
strategy and talked about the money you
could make I didn't believe it did you
not no I didn't believe it I thought no
it's can't be can't be done um but now
I'm here I'm doing it myself so that's
incredible and it benefits everybody you
know the landlord's happy their
properties at the highest and we
actually push the value up with the
property cuz it's not like a normal
tenant where they you know wreck the
properties or whatnot we keep it to we
have to keep it to a good standard
otherwise our business business model
wouldn't work I wouldn't be getting you
know reviews and um put on the platforms
so yeah it works everyone's happy and it
has to work for the landlord and I think
that it's a great there's a lot of
landlords that don't like the concept
and you'll say to them we want to rent
it we're then going to be renting it out
on short stets and there's quite a lot
of land maybe you've not found this but
generally they are like no no no we
don't want to do that we've heard that
before we're not interested where do you
think that skip ISM or that um those
objections where does that come from
from the landlords I think it's just a
lack of knowledge and um they don't see
the value in it you got you got to make
them understand uh what the business is
about And when they see your portfolio
now it's a lot easier for me because
I've got a lot when they see my follows
and stuff what I do and I've got reviews
from landlords as well they change their
mind on things yeah so um I understand
where they come from CU they've some
landlords we've had they've had tenants
and they've wrecked the prop properties
and whatnot and they're more they're so
negative they think you know and they
don't like people coming in and out of
the property so much like we we have
check-ins and checkouts you have to help
them understand how how it benefits them
what are the advantages to the landlord
renting it to you and getting their rent
from your company versus renting it to a
normal Talent well we we give guaranteed
rent we keep the property up to very
high standard and they get their you
know guaranteed rent on the date yeah
with the current market we've actually
been giving them more than the rental
value so about 10020 over cuz we can
afford to do that it's a couple of night
for us so um and you know that's say you
turn them around and make them
understand that this business is
beneficial so you're giving them more
money you're giving them a longer lease
you're giving them guaranteed rent and
sometimes people say how can you as a
new company guarantee the rent well you
can guarantee the rent with a contract
yeah yeah and if you don't pay the rent
and you're a normal tenant yeah it's
very difficult for the landlord to get
you out yeah but if you don't pay the
rent as a company with a commercial
lease agreement they can get you out 21
days yeah 21 days we're out so um when
they think about that and we give them
the contract you know nine nine times
out of 10 I've had success rate there
and you can show them look here's some
properties we've taken on before we're
actually going to be improving your
property we're going to be keeping it
done to a really high standard the
people coming in and coming out is good
because it means that every few days
we've got an inspection on the property
cleaners in there your property is going
to be kept to perfect standard we won't
leave a hair on the bed you're going to
get full rent and even maybe a little
bit more so it's a kind of a no
no-brainer already from the L
perspective did you face a lot of
rejection when you first started yeah
obviously because I didn't um the the
first couple a few times we did have
rejection but when when you show them
the value and they see you as a person
how you come across yeah I think you can
you know they a few landord that's come
back to me now that rejected me in the
past so um they did come around to it
yeah
and when once they understand the
business model um they think yeah this
this will work yeah so yeah what deals
are you currently working on I know
you've got a couple of lease options
that you're in negotiation yeah I've got
I've I've got a couple of lease options
that come afterwards so I'm doing rent
to service accommodation so all my
rental rents so two of them um I see the
landord struggling and he wanted to
offload his portfolio U so I pitched uh
lease option to him and he's interested
um that's two of the landlords so um
that's going through what do you say
then to a landlord so let's say and how
are you finding these deals like when
you're finding these properties are you
finding them on right move are you are
you going on gum tree are you are they
off Market how are you how are you
finding these landlords I'm in a
position where now the landlords and the
agents are coming to me that's a good
position to be in very good and that
happens quite quickly that happens quite
quickly because they seen the value so
initially it was gum tree open rent
right move going out to agents you know
uh calling um going there but right now
I'm in a position where i' landlords are
coming to me I haven't done that for a
long time now you've not had to cold go
or it's just coming to you it's coming
to me I've got landord agents with
portfolios and yeah um slowly slowly
we're just taking them on what would you
say the breakdown is in percentage to
the landlords where you've got landlord
direct versus agents going through
agents uh 50/50 really yeah 5050 I found
out with agents that to when you have to
convince an agent to work with you and
you show them your business model we do
company lets this is how it works it's
quite difficult getting your foot in the
door but once you've got one agent that
sees it and it becomes a proven thing
then they'll start picking up the phone
and saying oh we got another landord we
got another landord and they'll stop
bringing you loads of deals yeah so yeah
so one of my first projects was uh uh I
took on fre units in one yeah it's it's
like a whole block in Essex and uh that
was that for an agent and they were very
skeptical first um but now he's got a
list of properties to give to me he's
like he's going out his way he's like a
SAA you know give him a little fee um
and uh he just keeps coming back so it's
it's a good position to be in right now
talk to me about the management side of
things you've got a lot of units at the
moment £60,000
turnover that's that's a huge business
really that you've got now how are you
managing the portfolio do you have staff
do you manage it yourself do you have
Freelancers how does that work yeah
systemization and organization is a is
is key to scale up fast we have a
cleaning and staging team we have a
maintenance manager I've decided to
admin staff cuz I need my back ends to
all that and all my finances and rest of
it I just I'm just out there networking
and finding properties and doing the
viewings myself there's certain things
that I can't Outsource but like you say
Outsource everything so that's where I'm
going and you know thankfully we got off
to a good start you know I've worked on
the relationships with the landlords and
the guests um and you know we're still
living of those contacts to this day so
what was the hardest thing in the
beginning like when you first when you
were first at that one pound crash
course what was the biggest chall I
started in uh October uh no November so
it's nearly been a year and I got my
first property in um April 2nd and it's
all on my Instagram the whole story is
there and it was overthinking
procrastination and like how am I going
to do this I'm thinking about the
websites like I'm thinking about small
things that were kind of ir they were
they needed but kind of irrelevant I
wasn't taking action as soon as I
started taking action the day I started
taking action I got a whole I got free
Flats yeah yeah so um yeah what did you
think when you got that first deal and
you got three in one like how did you
feel about that I was still a bit scared
I I was skeptical still a lot but cuz
obviously I've paid money for the
Academy I've done that investment um
I've just taking on a property now I'm
black £20,000 down yeah and I'm thinking
at that point wow so we set it up we set
the first one up but once that first
booking come through of £3,000 when it's
not even ready yet um that's it the
whole it was just free for it's like a
Snowball Effect after that yeah how
important do you think it is because I
know you've you know you've made a lot
of good friends like tesshi and many
people on the academy how important is
it having people around you kind of
doing the same thing couldn't have done
it without them
I mean you know the the network uh
especially in the academy with
yourselves and stuff the sport I
wouldn't I wouldn't have known I
wouldn't know none of this the
strategies all I knew was straight
single at um the education the network
the support if I pick up a phone call to
the twins
govern govern Mitch you know I get
advise anybody Billy King so when I
wanted um lease option agreement like
get Billy a CO and we know he's the king
of L options I how do I P it yeah one
phone call it's that easy like how
wouldn't if I never had him there if I
had a network with networked I wouldn't
have know none of that yeah so yeah it's
very helpful and it's key it's key to
you know a scaling up what did your
family think when you said you were
getting into property I didn't tell them
you didn't tell them no I didn't tell
them I didn't I just I just done I just
done my thing I mean you know the easy
go and it's you know but I had to do it
um I'm at a point in my life where I had
to make certain um moves and you know
um I just I didn't tell them I didn't
tell them at all so when did they find
out uh they found out when I started
calling them to help me
out you I got a property like M Mama
didn't tell her uh so you know come and
help me out to clean the property and
stuff like that yeah so now they got to
know what's happening what do what do
they think now of what you've achieved
they love it they love it they enjoy it
they enjoy the cles you know where does
your drive come from cuz clearly I mean
you might see you and think oh you
chilled out you know relaxed and and you
are but you must have a crazy work ethic
to be able to have achieved so fast what
you've achieved and you must have a lot
of fire in your belly yeah driving you
I've got you know you got to keep the
goals higher you got to keep pushing
those goals um for me I want to make a
generational wealth um I've got I want
to free my time um I'm working fulltime
I've got charity is going on I've got
other things going on so for me this was
about making my income passive mhm yeah
so once that's passive I can give time
to other things and you know do things
that I want to do and like you say I
want to be able to wake up after
a wake I want to be able to wake up what
did you say I want wake up when you
finish sleep not when my L wakes me up
yeah yeah something like that yeah so I
want to be in that kind of situation so
we're getting there get in there I'm
still grafting what do you do on the
charity side CU I know you've you've
done a lot of water projects yeah I do
since 2016 when it comes to Ramadan I I
start collecting money for water wells
uh cuz the water shortage around
Africans like Far East you know it's
crazy so um it's something that I've
always been involved in charity um so I
collect money and we build whatever
collecting that month we build water
wheels so up up until now I've been
involved in about 100 water whe
in Africa and so you know Asia so no
good for you man yeah so and that gives
you a reason as well does why why to
work hard I know you've also you've sold
a few deals I think as well yeah I've
sold two deals I've sold two deals um
they wer in my patch and he's from my
own land was are coming to me
approaching me um was that easy easy to
sell was it hard how did you sell them
talk me through the process of selling a
deal well I just I just called up uh put
it on the academy chair call up on a few
people I sold it with the day it was
such a good deal in Watford um it's fire
bed house nicely done up you know we
helped how much you make though how much
you charge for 3,000 and you done that a
couple times yeah so you made about six
grand but still that's like half the
academy money back yeah yeah how did you
feel just after you join the academy did
you feel like a sense of relief like I'm
in now or did you or were you still
skeptical even after you joined uh mixed
reactions cuz with me it was more about
time it was um how am I going to how I'm
going to have time to do this
um I took a few months off work for
other reasons which helped me um study
and you know learn all the the whole
process get compliances and stuff in
order and it still took uh a few months
of thinking and finding and this and
that it was a heart you know you got to
keep persistent yeah persistence is key
you got to keep trying something will
give and you know that breakthrough will
come and when it come and I knew when
when that breakthrough comes I'm not
there's no stopping me yeah and then I
put I think it was the third deal or the
second deal oh after this my first deal
I got three Apartments straight away and
you you said in the WhatsApp group let
it when it rains let it Pour yeah so I'm
just letting it happen it's so true
because there's a lot of people that get
get a few deals and they might be making
a couple how much do you make off of
those three Deals we make 8,000 profit
in those three eight grand a lot of
people would almost semi- retire off of
that yeah yeah they'd be like okay I've
got my fast pound sword I got eight
grand a month coming in now let me go
straight to development and straight to
this or now let me just retire whereas
you I said to you when it rains let it p
man take the most of the the fact that
you got cool that's your momentum keep
going going going hard hard hard and you
definitely took that to heart yeah
definitely definitely that you know that
plays on my mind every other day I'm
thinking you know what I do think about
other strategies and I will go into
those strategy but while it's raining
let it po yeah how important is
compliance though because um I know you
said you spent a little bit of time
making sure you were compliant going
through the different areas
understanding the rules legislation how
important is that in 100% you got to be
fully compliant it gives you that sense
of security that you're backed up
contracts compliances they're very
important um if you don't have them in
order you know anything can happen you
can and the government will will make an
example of you as well yeah exactly if
you're not doing it legitimately that's
right yeah what's been the biggest
challenge uh biggest challenge time yeah
for me personally um finding that time
to actually go ahead with this business
uh was a was a big challenge especially
if I got so much gun in life um but no
you've had you've had personally
speaking you've had a lot of stuff on I
know your dad passed away a couple years
ago yeah dad passed away a couple of
years ago and that actually changed my
mindset fully before that you know I'm
in a good job I'm a manager I control
about 60 people but it's a job you know
it's still a job I still have to AR
someone I still have to wake up on time
and you know I want to be able to do
what I want to do and when I want to do
it why did did that change when your dad
passed when Dad passed I'm the eldest at
the siblings and when Dad passed I felt
um I've had to step in issues yeah that
gives me a lot more responsibility
taking care of my mom uh the rest of the
family and I needed time to do that so
um me being at work it just didn't cut
anymore do was content before that you
know 55 60,000 salary it's not bad for a
job you know going of two three holidays
a year
um but now I need to think about the
rest of the family and create that
generational wealth and make everybody
comfortable yeah yeah are the family
doing property now as well uh no not not
not at the will they will be they will
be why make 60 Grand a year when you can
do 60 Grand in a month yeah yeah 100%
yeah why I'm the kind of guy that was
like I'll show you rather than talk
about it um so if you if if they seeing
me do it they will be influenced you
know brothers are asking me already so
where I can they will slot in and I
think confidence in my in my experience
confidence comes from knowledge and
confidence comes from actually results
yeah when you when you when you get your
first deal and you see the cash flow
coming in yeah your confidence shoots up
and then obviously you're going to
perform better yeah yeah you just got
you just got to take that and just slide
with it just got to keep going and
that's what we've done how did you
justify investing so much into yourself
before you started growing your
portfolio how did you justify that
decision I've had to it's education I've
had to pay you know you got you got to
pay for your education you can get
educated but to have um like the academy
we've got mentors in place we've got the
network we've got yourself uh to have
and it just makes everything easier once
I thought of that and I thought yeah
this this is the right place this the
right environment to be and you got to
be in that environment and um to succeed
if your environment is Winners you're
going to win exactly that yeah exactly
so you know You' got more chances of win
you just got to take action and you know
you've made it so so easy for us I mean
all the contracts in place I've got them
on my phone I could you know just like
send a contract there and then normally
on a normal circus where would I find
that contract go to SL we do you know
we've got everything on the portals yeah
so and when you work hard at the same
time yeah yeah you know yeah have you
had any nightmare guests or nightmare
box I have I've have I've had the
wreckage tell me about it what happened
in my apartment uh she was a guess she
was there for a month she paid me 3,000
and um when she left the place was a
wreck I mean she's broken everything uh
and on top of that left us a bad review
on Airbnb damn why um I don't know I
don't know I don't know what it was
don't know why like you know I keep
relationships good with everyone and she
was good but don't how did you deal with
that she left a bad review with she flew
off she was from another country she
flew off uh and we told her this is the
situation um and we just went through
Airbnb uh so we're prot in that sense we
got paid back all the damages her review
got taken off so it's all good at the
end that's good yeah so got the
maintenance guy going fix it all up and
Airbnb just reimburses you for
everything reimburses for everything
that was like we turned it around in a
couple of hours luckily that's why SST
having your teams is very important so
the cleaning team the maintenance team
otherwise if I didn't have that I'd be
doing it myself and that's enough you
know few but that will put a lot of
people off some people not try because
they're worried about a Horror Story
happening but there's always Solutions
yeah there's always Solutions how you do
with it it's a m it's how you deal with
problems you're always going to get
problems like you say you you always
going to have problems how you deal with
them yeah you got to be a problem solver
where and how did you choose the
locations because you're in Essex right
so ah that that took me ages in the
beginning like I was thinking yeah I'm
in London um East London Canary Wolf's
like 10 minutes away from me that was my
patch that was my initial patch um then
I'm thinking about the 90-day Rule and
procrastinating on that that took ages
this that and then the rental prices um
so I thought let me just go outside of
London so my first units were just
outside just outside the M25 unproven
area you know all the webs adna wasn't
but I just went for it I just thought
you know what how wrong can I Cas it's
in the middle of the High Street um
there's a station five minutes walk away
that go straight into Central London um
you know just just took the chance and
yeah yeah do you think some people spend
so much time overthinking things like
their area that was me yeah that was and
then they don't get anything done yeah
yeah it's true and time just goes you
got to be fast you got to be fast since
since I got my first break in you know
April 2nd I just I just been Relentless
nonstop yeah just take it on and also
you never know 100% even if the area is
tried and tested you never know 100% how
it's going to go and how many bookings
you're going to get until you just do it
so as long as you've got a break clause
in place as long as you don't put way
too much money into the deal that you
can't get back as long as you structure
it properly and safely and sensibly and
you set it up such a way whereby even if
it's it goes terribly wrong I'm not
going to really lose much money yeah
yeah you got to think about a worst case
scenario yeah uh think about wor worst
case scenario and work your way out from
this or like you say break Clauses uh in
the contract are very important for me
uh I I would put 6 months to and a year
so if even if it doesn't work worst case
scenario 6 months later you can give the
property back yeah just just start from
the worst case scenario and work your
way upwards yeah uh so you're protected
how how do you furnish the properties do
you lease them do you buy them or do you
take properties we started one of my
first property was uh in hartfordshire
which I actually got sourced um and I
spent so much money in there it's my
first one yeah I bought you know like a
so for £400 which I could have picked up
£35 later on I realized on on Facebook
at Marketplace and stuff like that that
was in the beginning I spent a lot of
money but now we got companies that come
and deliver
everything cuz yeah we're in that
position we're allowed someone to be
hands off so paying that a little bit
extra um we pick what we want beds
furniture TVs from one company and they
just come and deliver it on the day or
the next day nice how do you work out
how much profit you're going to had to
making a deal or how do you work out if
a deal is good or bad cuz I'm sure
there's some properties that you come
across whereby the landlord's up for it
it seems great but you do the numbers
and you think oh I don't think this is
going to work yeah there there has been
there there has been properties like
that but then you got you got you got to
check check the market uh the rent the
rent will we try reducing I'll haggle
everything I'll haggle everything down
you know unless you know you're going to
make a fortune then you'll pay extra
yeah and then you check the nightly
rates uh of what's going on around the
area London London London you can't you
can't go much wrong and especially right
now um there's so much demand cuz what's
happened is we've worked at the the
hotels are fully booked with people that
are homeless
and uh that are looking for
accommodation so there is a market there
so most of the hotels around London and
around are with um uh people that are
looking for temporary accommodation so
where where do people go that come for
like two nights days or for a holiday
visiting they're going to come to us
yeah have you had any tenants that have
not paid or any guests that have not
paid and have refused to go uh no no
haven't had that no nothing yet no we're
protected like that we like um what
would you do if they did if if a guest
refused to pay if a guess a guest refus
we have to I don't know when that comes
you probably pick up the phone book a
mentor and call yeah that's it pick up a
phone called book a mention get some
advice from the academy get somebody you
know get them out somehow we get out
I've had it yeah yeah so yeah so they
we've not had that yet because the thing
is as as a tenant it's much harder but
as a guest with your business model if
they don't pay it's the same as if
you're at a hotel if you're at a hotel
and you don't pay they'll just kick you
out straight away yeah there's no reason
why they shouldn't you know we get the
money beforehand anyway yeah you charge
up front yeah so and the other thing is
you got to keep a good relationship with
everyone yeah I'll keep a good
relationship with not only my landlords
and agents with also the guest every
single guests uh the first guest that
come in I'm still talking to this day
yeah it's just relationships how you
build them paying attention yeah and
they're the ones that going to leave
your review I think today uh should be
us one of very close to becoming a Super
host I just got a message so your
superhost title is coming real soon yeah
so I need one more review but I've got a
couple of bookings before in the next
few days so one more review and you're
super host yeah yeah yeah that's
obviously a big deal to you how will it
feel when you become super host wow
that's that's a celebration just there
that's a celebration are you going to be
at the awards night Saturday I will be
yeah I will be I will be at the awards
what advice would you give to yourself
from a year ago when you were just sort
of looking into this and you're
skeptical and move faster move faster
just don't think too much and just you
know if the numbers add up and your risk
is low just go for it at the beginning
yeah yeah that's it just just move fast
Lu I'm moving now but how's life changed
in the last year life's still hectic in
terms of Finance yeah I'm I'm more you
know I'm £30,000 a month it's is no joke
is what are you doing with that are you
whacking it away are you investing
reinvesting I mean we're put we're
putting £10,000 aside for uh bigger
projects so I'll be looking at brrs and
stuff like that um we're taking a uh you
know a percentage of vaging but most of
it we're reinvesting and just scaling up
scaling as much as I can scale up to
targets £1,000 a month that sounds
realistic considering you turnning over
60 already yeah when I started in
January I ripped my goals down like you
you know make us write goals down I WR
goal 10 essays by the end of the year oh
God day in six months well huge respect
to what you've done it's real been a
real pleasure working with you I'm
excited about seeing the progress over
the coming months and years my brother
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
love